[Music]
landon
is with us in charlottesville virginia
hi landon how are you
i'm very well thanks for taking my call
dave and thanks for what you guys do
sure thank you how can we help yeah my
questions related to
um maybe a refinance type situation
a life phenomena fortunate enough we uh
we paid off our primary residence this
year
uh right before covet so that was a lot
of peace brought to our house but
we still have um a rental property that
has about 40 percent
debt tied to it roughly 140 000
it's quite worth around 300. so i've
looked at maybe refinancing that to a
15-year note to reduce the rate
but since i would have to get a
commercial product that doesn't really
necessarily make a whole lot of sense
but i thought wonder what your thoughts
should be of maybe
doing a cash out refinance on my primary
residence
to get like a really good rate roughly
two two and a half percent on a 15-year
note
then pay off the rental which would then
obviously significantly
increase the cash flow and obviously
allow maybe pay a house off
a little bit quicker i'm reluctant
because i don't want to
put the primary residence back under a
mortgage
that's the last one yeah yeah that
remember that part where you said i had
peace during covid yeah
no more peace but i remember that part
that was early in the conversation but
it still rings in my ears it was a
wonderful phrase
and i don't i would never steal that
from you you finally got there i'd sell
the rental before i did that i don't
want to sell the rental what's your
household income
um around 150 give or take but that it
varies
so how fast you're going to pay off 140
yeah
um we got some money i mean if we put
our nose to it we could probably do it
three to five years probably
you got some money what's that mean well
we've got a little bit of money we've
got like
40 50 sitting an account that's um
that's not the emergency fund yeah
correct okay so now we only got to pay
off 90. yeah i like this
i like this yeah and what's the interest
rate yeah
uh right now it's set from five percent
oh whoop-dee-doo
just pay it off dude don't refi man
don't refi just go ahead and just pay it
off you got 90k
at 150. you can have it actually paid
off in about two two and two and a half
years
three and a half three to five years is
too long for me for four grand a month
and you're done in under two years
yes yeah yeah yeah all right well
that's that answers that yeah and then
the refinance cost makes these
savings on the interest irrelevant
because you're doing it so fast yes
yeah that's true landon that's true
don't hang up the phone and
uh refi your home dude don't do that
he's not going to so landon let's let's
kind of walk back through
what we just did uh for you and
so you can do it again for you and other
people can too
you were using two parts of yourself to
make the decision and they were in
conflict
your heart and your head your hearts
were your measure risk
and that's where you said i was glad
during covet i had peace because i
didn't have a mortgage
my head got over and started doing math
and i'm trying to crunch these numbers
and save on the interest rate yeah
okay and they got in conflict with each
other now when that happens with me and
both are valid ways of making a decision
but when they're in conflict with each
other something's wrong
because they both have your best
interest at heart
no kidding i mean heart and head but i
mean they both have your best interests
your heart and your head do so
one of the things i've learned to do is
i learned to take the math and turn it
into dollars
which is what i just did i didn't do it
physically on this call
but what we said was the amount of
actual dollars
that you're going to end up saving given
that we reduce this down to 90
and you're going to do it in two years
or so the amount of actual dollars saved
by getting a two or
three percent versus a five is very
small
okay and so it becomes not worth it when
you shift your strategy around
and you say how can i have a math
strategy and a heart strategy a head and
a heart strategy
that are running parallel and that's
when it suddenly goes it's a no-brainer
we know what to do here
the heart and the head are lined up we
we measure risk in the heart we do math
in the head
yeah and so you're you've got both of
these things lined up and you're heading
the right way
and what happens is we either go heart
yes or we go ahead we go
all about the emotions and the risk and
we can feel it all over here on one hand
and people make decisions only over
there and they don't do any math right
well that'll get you killed
right sure will or they just do
everything with the math and they don't
take into consideration i just put my
house back at risk
which he knew he wasn't going to yes and
he knew we wouldn't we're going to tell
him to nope i would not tell him to i'll
actually scream at him but this is your
show
but landon here's the key thing though
you said it we have to put our heads
down and we have to go after it okay
this
this plan that me and dave just gave you
will only make sense
if you honestly just take these next two
years
and aggressively go after it yeah but
he's making 150 48 he ain't getting
other bills
yeah he could you know and you that's a
good rental keep that rental i mean
because here what's the end of this
story the other story he's got to pay
for house paid for rental
ding ding this guy's heading on
millionaire status real fast real fast
i like that well done well done well
done